ladies and gentlemen welcome to a
special edition of the timbaland show i
don't usually do this but i have my
attorney
on skype with me right now because this
is a legal matter i am being defamed and
slandered
um by the new york post
my attorney ray comp please because this
is a you know it's not a legal
proceeding but it's not not a legal
proceeding please state your name and
your law firm for the record
this is uh raymond uh gerard kump
uh i represent uh
wolf spool
uh
legal legal proceedings uh it's a firm
out of uh
delaware
and i i wanted to be known that we we
will be seeking
every legal remedy in this in this
heinous uh egregious uh affront of the
truth uh i am in contact with the hague
uh also um private contractors this is
uh
an affront to
your livelihood
to the basic tenets of uh i also am i
getting paid for this as a lawyer
here's the deal we want to catch
everybody up to speed on this
ben can you um is your ipad gonna lock
up every five minutes five seconds
the new york post just wrote an article
about a house i bought in the hamptons
it is stemmed to stern
completely all lies and fabrications
literally i mean we're kidding ray's not
really a lawyer
but
not yet
that's true
that being said this article is all
lies right
there's not there's not almost not a
single truth
you you could if you were trying to
create this information yes you wouldn't
have this many lies in it i don't know
what purpose it serves to lie i just
hate lying
like this it's stupid it says comedian
tim dillon slaps down four million
dollars for a hampton spread that is a
headline of an article in the new york
post written by jennifer gold the house
was listed for 2.6 million dollars i
bought the house for 2.55
uh
million dollars around there
there is
there's some change i did not slap no
it's a good amount of money but i did
not slap down
four million dollars that's a lot you
know what you're you know what they're
doing there i don't know what they're
doing they're they're they're they're
alluding to your [ __ ] they're saying
like you slapped them like you're some
[ __ ] me too scumbag i have no
slappings did i have a four-inch [ __ ]
i'm slapping around at the hamptons
but it's by the way this is the title of
the article it's the headline the
headline is comedian tim dillon slaps
down 4 million
so let's take this line by line don't be
surprised if you spot comedian podcast
king which again stop there's only one
podcast king we know who it is
mark maron now
kidding
it's um
adam carolla
kidding again it's ray
um
this is gross they compare me uh heir to
counter cultural grades like george
carlin no one has ever said that
the only thing is that i talk about
society so does he he's the good the
greatest well let me see what george
carlin did on his deathbed kind of
conferred to you like you know right it
was a responsibility for like george
carl would have loved houses in the
hamptons that was this whole big thing
right real estate
um
recently closed on a 3.9 million south
hampton home lie
down from his 4.5 million asking price
lie
this is all la it's insane to me the
house is 2.5 million dollars
it's
insane to lie about this
it they then say
also just in time also
yeah he goes
he owns homes in beverly hills in austin
texas i do not own a house in beverly
hills
right that's crazy i don't own it i
would love to
i don't have 25 million dollars that is
a lie i do not own a home in beverly
hills i do own a home in austin
next on his list is manhattan that is
not true i have no plans to buy anything
in manhattan probably ever you have told
me on multiple occasions the methods of
which you would kill yourself before you
lived in manhattan yes i'm not going
back to manhattan
um
it also says
that
it's crazy they go
he completed a whirlwind comedy tour
from france to italy to all the major
cities in australia i have not ever
performed comedy
in france or italy
that was not on the tour at all like
that it's completely
untrue
this article is basically mad libs it's
mad libs it's just fill in the blank
it's he's slapping four millions of
dollars that i don't have
he owns homes in beverly hill it's a
complete lie i it's trying to make me
sound better but it's all lies and
fabrications
i'm starting with where is where is the
part of it that says i started comedy in
2008. oh and the yeah
where is it is that true that's yeah
started doing comedy 2008 following the
economic crisis that's not true i
started doing it in 2010
late 2010 almost 20 what i mean is that
who
like who does any of the fact checking
this is all
fake
this is more egregious than the iraq war
like uh
misinformation and and more damaging
yeah
but no it's the
the the idea here is that they just get
a bunch of [ __ ] they don't fact check it
my realtor called me and said
do you mind if your your information got
leaked to the new york post that you
bought this house
and i said i and she goes i don't know
how that happened and i wanted to say
well i have a guess you called them and
leaked it that's my guess like every
realtor ever leaked [ __ ] i'm not nearly
famous enough where anyone would give a
[ __ ] about where i live who gives a [ __ ]
so i said to her i don't think anyone
will care
if they got the info and they're
printing a little dumb blurb i don't
really give a [ __ ] don't put my address
in it but i don't want a [ __ ] article
of lies
this is uh i mean this isn't like a
person who's trying to rebuild their
career right
she's a realtor that was really hot back
in the day and now
is been displaced by the instagram set
of probably younger
more
you know social media savvy
uh set of realtors but she had a moment
where she was number one
she was the first really famous realtor
out there
and she's got a great relationship with
the press she's on tv all the time and
you know she did a great job with the
house but i don't know is it her fault
is she feeding the post all this fake
information
how was the post getting this from a
good run too but you know what'd you say
fidel castro had a good run also he had
a great run
that's different
but you know look i is this her trying
to spruce it up in her mind like you
know
like
all you know the fact oh he was in
france in italy like something like a
like some carnival barker yeah it does
kind of read like they're trying to
dress me up they're like he slapped four
million after etor alitalia of comedy
he was in the mediterranean doing comedy
on boats like it it's just so
not researched and it's so weird
and i don't know what role she had in it
other than i imagined that's how they
found out
which is that everybody didn't like say
you went you were like you have a house
and i beat them
yeah why not say that i spent 20 million
dollars on a house in the hamptons
after
uh performing for the pope
like i had a private audience with the
pope at vatican city it's as true as
this article
this is
they use the worst picture the worst and
better put this picture up and i'll
close up it is the most disgusting photo
i've ever think it's almost like you if
you don't hate me already
you look at this photo and you go i want
him dead
yeah which which show was that from i
the netflix thing i did maybe a couple
of years ago i don't even know right
but they
look like you look like you're like i'm
drunk or something in this photo i look
so disgusting like you would hate and by
the way they're showing a part of the
hamptons i don't live in
i'm not near the beach like look at that
dad in family court like
look i know i hit the kids i look like a
dad and family quarters realizing he
doesn't really want visitation
he's going what am i doing this all for
but it's like i just don't know how they
can get away with like lying like this
is that even is your house even in that
shot no
the shot
is of like [ __ ] estates
right it's like
that's billionaire beach it's not at all
what is this
what kind of game is this
this this is uh what what they call that
the um hyper normalization
this is them trying you know trying it's
like a soviet level
you know disinformation campaign just to
create
uh
you know chaos about you
what if adam curtis started his next
documentary with
in 2022
a comedian bought a house in southampton
for 4.5 million for 4.5 million
it wasn't immediately clear then but a
chain of events had taken place no but i
just don't know do i have any recourse
can i sue anybody i mean this is all
this is complete insanity i mean look
you could definitely uh
i mean
look i don't think defamation suits uh
are typically ever won
one he might get one well right but yeah
i mean
he's got a little different uh
yeah i mean look
it would be nice if we got a six week
trial out of this can we do that
well they covered the same way as the
deaf per trial i don't think it's as
exciting to people as depp heard that's
real juicy and real entertaining
what if i say what if i say she hit me
the realtor
yeah
i'll go on the stand i absolutely would
i would love if you did that yeah
on my face
she called me she said you know you're
not allowed in this house
uh
she made she made me uh you use you know
go to the toilet in the street
i'm wondering how responsible is she for
this and how responsible is the writer
of the article
who should i be angry at
is there is there any there's no like
board of journalism right like there's
no like ethics committee there's no bar
association right like you're just
clearly not clearly you can just make
[ __ ] up
this is like worse than shattered glass
that movie we're like yeah in
christensen
this is like uh
i just don't know why you just just
print the real [ __ ] go yeah bought a
house for two and a half million bucks
don't why wouldn't they call you why
would they not why would they lie oh
it's he's four million dollars he's
performing in france he owns a house in
beverly hills none of this is true it's
not accurate
this isn't an expose like why would my
parents my parents are calling me
they're like you own a house in beverly
hills i'm like no it's fake
i mean it's like i'm giving them more of
a reason to hate me
they're like worried because it's like
you know what during the mortgage days i
bought that house and foreclosed it's
like these all these articles are like
he owns 17 houses everybody's like yeah
he's gonna go
they're like oh he's gonna burn and it's
like yeah it's untrue i own a house in
austin that's under a million bucks
cheap house and i bought this thing and
that's it and then there's like this
[ __ ] insane
idea
that's going around that the one thing
is i did dance the poke with
snuffleupagus on sesame street that's
the one [ __ ] thing they got right one
thing they got right
i mean look uh
do you even want that you heard me like
all the things in the article to
actually even get right he's like who
cares but like
i mean
is this person like
are these things you told the uh the
realtor at some point no like oh i was
in i was in france like you know you
know for a visit
and like
i don't think so
this is like when you talk to a decrepit
grandmother yeah and it's like you know
what are you doing oh yeah you know i've
been doing uh you know
are you the president of the company no
i work in the mail room grandma i mean
what how does this work like be the part
be the writer from the post i'll be the
realtor
all right uh is this tim dillon
no this is his representative hi we'd
like to ask uh we have an article coming
out about his house in the hamptons and
we'd like to
you know just uh fact check a few things
uh
did you know he's a billionaire
we did not know uh we can we confirm is
he friends with uh salomon
of saudi arabia do you know not only is
he friends do you know that he is in
line to the throne of saudi arabia very
very good
mohammed bin salman and then him
that's what it is i'm just i'm kind of
pissed off that it's lies
i i wanted to put out a video with you
talking about it you think i should go
real scorched earth on these people
which maybe i should
i think i i would i'm saying the realtor
i would love to just tear into this
person uh and you know this is the idea
she thinks she's gonna like rebuild her
career on the back on your back i don't
know she's rebuilding her career i think
she has a fine career
well
not if i have anything to say about it
i think
this is just the way they play the game
they leak [ __ ] and it's lies it's all
lies they just did it to trevor noah in
l.a it's lies
i don't know they lied about the prize
they lied about everything but they were
right that he bites children right
that was true
the thing about him biting children was
a one-time thing
where a mother brought her child and
said please bite him
and trevor noah finally agreed to it for
a picture
but trevor bit too hard and the kids
started bleeding and screaming but the
mother the mother thought that was a
better picture so she said keep going
keep going he was it was in penn station
outside of where they do the orange
julius and and trevor got caught up at
the moment going to keep going keep
going so he kept biting and the kid was
squirming and he was bleeding and they
took a photo but again it's not a big
deal but for i'm just mad about the lies
no you deserve better we mean look i
i know the new york post should we go to
every open house this woman does with
bomb strapped to ourselves no i'm asking
i'm asking if we should go to every open
house with bombs strapped to ourselves
i don't see how there's any other
way about if you guys would look like us
walk to every open house and go we used
to live here
because that might just kill every deal
if me and you let's say we stood outside
every open house and said we used to
live here and we [ __ ] in every room of
this house
every inch of this house i walk up to
like the woman and i'm like hey i used
to live here i know it's a really good
hiding place
and you go like this you go like this
you look at her and you go property like
to a property like this really keep you
safe
you'll be safe and warm because it's
scary out there
i still have the keys
my keys always work in this lock listen
to me
uh i i i don't know what we should do
how to enact revenge i mean showing up
to the open houses with bomb strapped to
ourselves telling people we used to live
in the house and [ __ ] there
um
i thought about making you into this
really high net worth buyer and trying
to fake documents and pre-approvals and
then when the woman saw you she would
kill herself
like she flies like a private jet to you
and then when you come out on the tarmac
she just decides none of it's worth it
and she takes her own life
i mean i'm down because i'm i'll try to
embezzle the money out of the situation
myself oh yeah you're not getting any
money out of this situation it's just
the satisfaction of a job well done
no i'm talking about embezzling i'm you
know i screwed the bank out of something
yes here's here's my old thing i'm just
i'm just wondering how we can get back
at these people i know
look we got name names we have to dock
and go after i mean what was i telling
you in the car when you told me that
burner we got burner like you know like
a foreign agent you know
she's gotta come in from the cold
what do they do to foreign agents
i'm saying when we when we when we like
leave a country you know uh like in
vietnam we had all the spies in vietnam
again we burned all those agents they
they got killed by the what about if you
make a complaint
with the real estate board of new york
saying she called you the n word would
you do that
hundred percent and take it
like you take this
out so why wouldn't i
she did say it to you didn't she no she
she said to me multiple times she said
you fat and work
n-word in the open house
right and it was unprovoked she
literally just walked up to you and said
you fat and work in front of a very nice
black family which i was so embarrassed
it was about and the guy looked at you
and he goes it's about power
and it was very interesting
but how do we do it i mean do we
i don't know i mean i think we need to
document i think we need to make a
documentary yeah about this situation
and we're going to get the guy from uh
from you know september 9 11 the
december 11th of new pearl harbor help
us with this
perhaps yeah i mean should we just start
today because it was a horrible tragedy
where 14 school students
school students were killed
should we
donate a bunch of money in her name to
the nra and start tweeting at her the
nra loves this realtor
that's golden yeah
like just today like nra loves dolly
today should i start a twitch twitter
handle and her and her like you know as
her and just start you know saying how
impersonated howard
can we in person
can we impersonate yes yes tweet
zelinski's a coward from her but can we
give her a fake twitter handle where we
tweet this quote i don't care what
happened in texas my rights are my
rights
and then just repeat like keep tweeting
that and then we'll tweet all her
listings like can we tweet like one of
her listings and then right after it
we'll tweet like q and on stuff and then
you know lovely three bedroom by central
park
you have to get this gun out of my cold
dead [ __ ]
[Music]
am i overreacting here
no i think you're under-reacting i think
this needs to go federal i think we need
to
you know uh international even i mean
look this is a person who has their
hooks into all sorts of uh you know
little dirty pots and we need to explain
what if were both served with lawsuits
like tomorrow morning
she's like
you two fat [ __ ] don't even know what
you're doing
you're out of your depth
she goes i'll kill both of you myself
i sell condos to tyrants
[Laughter]
she goes i tax vladimir putin once a
week
i'll have you both i'll have you both
killed
that's very foreseeable
it's not completely impossible because
what do they do otherwise what do they
do except have that kind of pull where
they have like putin on speed dial
that's the only reason you would be us
you don't think they do this to the
genocidal monster too you don't think
there's some [ __ ] guy in saudi arabia
sitting around going there say
80 million i spent 65.
oh no she she burned chavez i'm sure
yeah like
i'm sure they leaked these people's
information the oligarchs are not happy
with these people
i
i only killed three dozen people that
day
the lies
i don't know man
i have makeup on because i just did a
cool thing with rick rubin it'll be
coming out
and uh but as my attorney
you know i think i think the courts are
probably not the right way to handle
this there's got to be a way to handle
it
that allows us
you know to get creative
i think we can convince her to do like
the cinnamon challenge
hear me out
i tell her
a friend of mine is dying of an
incurable disease he has a few weeks
left to live
he just wants to see
this listing you have on central park
he's never looked out
of of a window on central park he just
wants to look
because maybe he used to live there and
his family lost all their money whatever
it doesn't matter he just for his dying
wish he just wants to look out this
window one time and we get her to agree
to it and then you get up in the
apartment and you start [ __ ]
everywhere
and rubbing your [ __ ] on the walls i
start acting like i'm going i'm going to
like anaphylactic shock
i just felt like like a whirling dervish
dude is like you get in there and you
start going hell satan
[Laughter]
um
yeah i just i'm up i just don't like
that everything about it's a lie and
that people my friends family calling me
going is this true is this true and i go
it's wrong it's wrong it's wrong it's
all wrong
i mean the one thing they're supposed to
do is like
like a good salesman like they remember
the name of your kids yeah and like you
know what your wife you know does for a
living and like the stuff that makes you
feel like uh right like whatever like
warm and like oh this person knows me
like those little like the dale carnegie
crap right right and like she's just
like blurring this stuff yeah i think he
was in france uh yeah he [ __ ] enough i
guess i don't know what it is i don't
know if it's dementia i don't know if
it's just a complete utter uh
no care for the truth
doubling the price of the house like
what is this
she's she's just she's flexing
i don't know man it's a weird flex i'm
not famous like that and no one gives a
[ __ ] what i do
so it's such a weird [ __ ] article
maybe they felt fell about understand
the internet like she thinks you're like
logan paul famous i don't know what
maybe but maybe they think that if they
don't lie about me no one will care so
they just start lying they're like he's
the biggest comedian in france and he
just spent nine million dollars on a
boat in southampton it's like all lies
right
he owns the beverly center
i mean it's it's it's just complete lies
it's unfortunate and i appreciate you
being here to help me correct the record
no of course i mean you know this is
this is a front that will not be uh
tolerating we'll not be stood how long
have we done been here about uh 25 yeah
this is 25 minutes we're not going to go
on too much longer i mean the reality is
we're we just wanted to correct a record
we've got a great episode coming out
this week
and
i appreciate it we brainstorm some ways
and we'll figure out one of them that's
appropriate
can you not hear me
what no yeah i know it was a question
yeah you are you're not gonna respond at
all
i think really yeah you're not
responding at all well no i gotta i
won't okay no look you're staring at me
i will you know what i want to do i want
to get i want to get our hands dirty
[Laughter]
you want a war
you want it i want b and b level lesbian
airbnb war
did they ever screw you over again no
that's i'm off airbnb well look that's
collateral damage i know
but i'll tell you this
i get what you're saying i'm unhappy
right i'm unhappy
with this
sunlight is the greatest disinfectant
that's right
so i think we need to leave her out in
the
nevermind
i didn't want to say
very she's a she's a very well-connected
woman so i i don't know what she had to
do with this i i am not
i don't know that it's her fault
if you haven't talked to her yet have
you no but i don't know if it's her
fault
we should let's call her right now she's
very good at her job that'll be a legal
thing
that'll be illegal i mean right ben
yeah that would be absolute legal thing
you know
it'll be a legal thing for sure look
i'm just saying that you know if
if i have my way
uh you're gonna be you're gonna be
having more than one house in the
hamptons you know sooner rather than
later
this is gonna go it's gonna be very very
good for both of us
yeah well i don't even know what that
means but i
want to go on record right now
i know what that means i just hate that
my friends and family the few of them i
have are calling me going wait what is
all of this
and i'm like they're like did you lie to
us you said the price was this i'm like
no i didn't lie to you they just make
sure why would you lie to them like what
do you like
yeah russia for two years and then
reversed themselves on that like they
lie they make [ __ ] up i don't know what
to do no no but i'm saying your family
like is this insane is this so funny
like your family hey are you lying about
how much you've been like what [ __ ] you
yeah they think i'm lying about
everything we have an article come out
in the new york post people go oh yeah
he's lying
right he's a liar
and it's it's a complete fabricated
article other than the fact that i
bought a house in hamptons but it's
complete fab everything's complete
fabrication
i mean i don't i don't know how you know
the new york post this was a disaster by
the way
this whole entire process like she was
very good at negotiating the deal you
know this woman but i don't know what
happened with this i do i'm not happy
about this
she's a great deal maker
but i'm really unhappy with this
for sure
and i mean worst pr since the o.j
simpson tried i mean it's just it's lies
so lies are not good right people lying
about you to make you look better or
make you look worse i don't know what
this makes me look like like no it looks
like i'm a member of the rama
rockefeller it's crazy this is the kind
of thing that can bite you in the ass
just because it's like it's public
information it's like it's a problem it
wasn't a paper of record or whatever the
hell i'm like yeah now you're trying to
like you know you're trying to get some
kind of uh work visa for like you know
whatever it is by the way does the irs
or whoever not go wait yeah like what
the [ __ ] you bought this house they go
oh well it says here you spend this i'm
like dude it's two and a half million
bucks it's not four million
no she's a house and it's nice but it's
not a spread this idea oh planks four
million down for hampton spread it's
crazy it's possible that she's using you
as some kind of money laundering scheme
um
like she's trying she's trying to
like she on her end she's saying 4.5
million she's got these like you know
bricks of heroin moving through your
house
you know some kind of scheme like that i
don't know if we should immediately go
to accusing her of selling heroin
well we didn't name names yet so it's
fine
the reality is this
everybody in this world is litigious
raymond do you know that
like i'm just speculating on what
possibly could be is it possible she's
selling heroin yes
no i don't think it's true
ray [ __ ] where do the people find you if
they want to find you
please check it out
the comp podcast is available on youtube
and wherever you get podcasts it's
hilarious you go check out my patreon
it's patreon.com
raycump uh you get an extra episode
every week for five bucks to have a
cigarette
can you smoke in your house
i cannot no
it would be a problem
what do you mean you live in a brooklyn
dump
i mean i guess like i mean there's like
fire
extinguishers in here although one time
i did they don't work right they don't
work that's for show
yeah
one time like i had
yeah we almost burned down the kitchen
and it didn't go off
so
your apartment is what 20 000 a month
that's nothing
you live in you live in the financial
district you pay 20 000 a month and you
earn that money coaching gymnastics
this is the new york post writer right
my forehand to high society ended very
quickly
yeah i mean this is a real
real rude awakening
can't they just be honest
true
this is why we need a
a disinformation board right
um perhaps banded that quick question
while i finished the cigarette what do
you think about the school shootings
i'm against it
i'm not i don't support it i think it's
heinous
it's hey it's a heinous crime
horrible
look i mean the reality is you like to
say we're going to do something about it
i see people tweeting and they're like
you know
we're going to do something and i just
feel like
you know it's just it's just routine now
which is crazy i mean i had
should we even report them anymore i was
talking about this on my podcast last
week i was spamming that's a great joke
he goes there were so many shootings
they bore me
but should we even talk like it's a bold
idea but like what if we just never
reported them
when they get out of people's system
that would be a good
point ray
thank you because i feel like at some
level even if we don't like we don't we
don't name them a lot anymore the people
who do it
but like it's still like you get
i thought they stopped printing their
names we name everyone but we shouldn't
we should pretend it didn't happen i
know i just said why did you shot all
those people in texas i just followed
him on tick-tock
are they is it good he's not bad
yeah
follow him i need to get a tic-tac more
i'm kidding i didn't follow my tick-tock
everybody
no but like i mean it's a problem this
is a special thing it'll be out well how
long do you think it'll take ben to put
this at seven eight days to correct the
record here
take him seven eight days
well the
audio doesn't really thank god man yeah
jamie he always because he's like jamie
and joe
well i don't know what to say anymore
i'm just fed up with the lies well darth
and prayers go out to the families
uh affected by this article
[Music]
right and uh that's right
that's right i think it's the most
pressing issue in the country today and
that's why
i mean it would be interesting you would
be people gonna see like a special
edition of tim dillon's show and they're
gonna assume it's about one thing but
it's really about
clearing up this real estate article
yeah no it's it's not what am i gonna do
with the shootings i can't
what am i gonna do
what am i gonna do i got these problems
with with realtors running their mouths
i can't get nothing involved with the
the weapons industry
yeah that's there's a little there's a
little too much to chew off
the expression no it isn't
ray kump everyone my attorney from what
was it woolworth where did you say you
were from woolworth's in the beginning i
think it's a bulls pool
it's like a word you can't even say i'm
from school
it's like you're amber heard's third
chair
yeah they're like it's not going well
who we're bringing on they're like we
brought on this guy from wolf's pool
let's listen to me
she's a dumb [ __ ] but so is he
who are you sir raymond comp esquire
wolf spool
i'm i work with wolf spool legal your
the name was wolf spool legal
proceedings
it sounds like the the a part of a
primerica which like literally they just
exist to like rob people in like bad
areas they put these like fake financial
centers with like brochures that are
like debt is good and like literally in
the corner of their office there's
something that says wolf spool legal
proceedings and you're just sitting
sweating eating a blimpy sandwich and
someone walks in and they're like i
haven't seen my daughter in three years
and you're like i can change that buddy
sit down
great comp everyone good luck everyone
don't tell your realtor [ __ ] good night